[Music]
on this thursday night the impending
crisis
of dangerous variants how ontario dreads
a tsunami of cases is coming
in just weeks as pfizer's vaccine
deliveries
diminish they've left the people of
canada
down triggering concerns the federal
government can't deliver
on its promises protecting indigenous
canadians the mission to restore
trust in the health care system a
poisonous
environment being humiliated and
screamed at the scathing independent
review
into the former governor general's
workplace and the battle between hedge
funds and amateur investors
[Music]
the story behind the frenzy of gamestop
stock
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the slow pace of canada's
vaccine rollout and a new warning the
rise of more transmissible variants of
covid19 could usher in
new waves of contagion in ontario a top
covid19 advisor says there is now clear
evidence
the uk variant is circulating in the
community
and it's described as a significant
threat
the new variants of concern the mutated
uh sars cov2 virus
are clearly spreading the community and
will likely be the dominant version of
the virus in march
around the world governments are racing
to roll out vaccines before these new
variants take hold
in canada it is slow going the federal
government has repeatedly said
every canadian who wants a vaccine will
get one by september
but we're not on target for that right
now here is canada's vaccination track
record
the number of doses administered was
rising in early to mid january
it has now plunged in large part because
promised shipments of the pfizer biotech
doses to canada
have stopped the company says it's
retooling its plant in europe so it can
scale up production
major general danny forte who is leading
the rollout in canada calls the delay
a bump in the road pfizer has assured us
that canada
will receive 4 million doses that they
had
previously indicated by and march so
they assured us of that
and we're working to that end with
pfizer
that promise though contradicts what the
provinces have been told they have been
asked to plan for three and a half
million pfizer biontech doses by the end
of march
and complicating all this is a push by
pfizer to stretch the number of doses in
each vial from
five to six but that requires a special
syringe
most vaccination sites don't have eric
sorenson has our top story tonight
the government's point person on vaccine
distribution couldn't be more clear
pfizer has assured us that canada will
receive 4 million doses by
end of march full stop except the
government is straining to explain
whether pfizer will actually deliver 4
million vaccine doses
ottawa's plan earlier this month showed
a steady rise to more than 300 000
pfizer doses to be delivered
each week to a total of almost 4 million
by the end of march
but a new planning document sent to the
provinces highlights the recently
announced cuts in pfizer deliveries
down to zero this week and much lower
numbers till mid-february
to a total now of just over 3.5 million
at the end of march
half a million fewer than before several
premiers are unhappy
pfizer has let us down tremendously it's
again unacceptable you know we they have
an obligation to meet the contract
adding confusion pfizer wants to change
the count for each vial of vaccine to
six doses from
five which could help make up for any
shortfall
but it's something health canada hasn't
approved yet what is the plan
the prime minister said he had a plan
the opposition is perplexed
suggesting the government is failing to
deliver what it planned
but the deputy prime minister insisted
pfizer's commitment
plus the doses from moderna will arrive
by the end of march
6 million will arrive by the end of the
first quarter and
every canadian who wants to be
vaccinated will be by september
the problem this country can only
administer what it receives
and that number for now is modest canada
has distributed vaccines largely in line
with the population of each province
in all distributing 1.1 million vaccine
doses across the country
the total administered so far more than
900 000
that's 81 percent most are just first
doses
doctors are concerned about any cutbacks
this winter because the most vulnerable
need vaccines sooner
not later the fact that this is phase
one it's the most vulnerable phase
it's the one that will stop
hospitalizations it'll stop mortalities
we need to get this vaccine into our
country and into people's arms as fast
as possible
ottawa insists the outlook remains
promising because vaccine deliveries
will ramp up to more than 20 million
doses between april and june
but until then the numbers will be low
and the anxiety will be high
eric sorensen global news toronto
here's another story about numbers
ontario has issued a major correction to
its vaccination database
the province says it inadvertently
double counted the number of completed
two-dose vaccinations the province had
been reporting just over 96 000 people
had received two doses
in fact that number reflects the total
number of doses administered
just 55 000 people in ontario have been
fully vaccinated with two shots
an ontario nurse has tested positive for
covid19 nearly two weeks after getting
the second dose of the pfizer biantech
vaccine
santos barrel says he doesn't have any
symptoms and
was speechless when he got the results
when
my my manager called me that i got
tested positive
i couldn't speak for for a while
how it happens you know i didn't feel
nothing
nothing nothing so far
barrel is isolating at home away from
his family experts say there are several
possibilities to explain his case
clinical trials show the pfizer biotech
vaccine as 95
effective so he may be among the 5
percent it doesn't work
on it takes a week to 10 days after
being vaccinated to become
fully immune and he may have been
exposed to the virus before the vaccine
took
full effect despite his situation barrel
is encouraging everyone to get
vaccinated and to follow all
public health guidelines despite a
scarcity of vaccines right now the
federal government is sticking to its
plan to vaccinate people on remote first
nations and
metis and inuit communities by this
spring there are more than 3 500
active cases of covid19 on first nation
reserves
144 people in those communities have
died
about 37 000 people in 196 indigenous
communities have received the
first dose of the vaccine shortages and
logistics are two big challenges but so
is a long history of racism
and mistreatment that's left a legacy of
mistrust in canada's health care system
mike lacatura reports and a warning some
of the images in his story
may be disturbing if the real
coronavirus
enters our body later as the kovit-19
vaccine rolls out to indigenous
communities
so too is an information campaign
including
pictures of chiefs and community leaders
getting their shots
some of it may seem hokey but it's the
counter a history
vaccine confidence is something that has
to be earned
in in communities natan obed represents
canada's 60
000 inuit while communities like new
nazi avoid in labrador say
71 percent of the adult population has
been given the first dose of the moderna
vaccine
there remains distrust considering the
experimentation on
innovate first nations and metis
children in residential schools
especially on nutrition supplements and
other
health research projects working against
legitimate fear of the healthcare system
in terms of
vaccines and deployment of the vaccines
in a culturally
safe fashion those experiences have been
passed down through the generations and
there's been a more recent example
video of joyce echequin being insulted
and degraded by
hospital staff in quebec exposed the
systemic racism indigenous people face
in the health care system it prompted a
two-day meeting between governments and
stakeholders
resulting in a path towards distinctions
based indigenous health legislation
issue of self-determination over over um
over health care is is key key foremost
as a matter of right but also as a
matter of
positive medical outcomes outcomes like
a safe and effective vaccine rollout to
all indigenous people
even those living off reserve in urban
settings
the national association of friendship
centers has offered to set up
vaccination clinics
to reach those people but there have
been issues
the day before the clinic was supposed
to happen
the hospital that was providing them
with the vaccine said the province won't
let us
give you some of our vaccines that
clinic alone would have immunized
60 high-risk indigenous people in
toronto instead
it had to be canceled and those
individuals are supposed to be the top
priority for vaccination according to
both the province
and the country mike lacouter global
news ottawa
with vaccines in short supply it's
imperative no dose goes to waste so
when some health care workers in oregon
got stuck in a snowstorm they came up
with a plan
they were driving back from a
vaccination clinic when heavy snow
stopped traffic
knowing their vaccine supply would
expire within a couple of hours they set
up an impromptu clinic
going from car to car and offering the
six remaining vaccines they had
to stranded motorists the independent
review that led to the downfall of julie
payet canada's former governor general
has now been made public
payette a former astronaut resigned last
week and the report makes clear why
dozens of employees describe the work
environment at rideau hall
as hostile toxic and poisoned
much of the report is blacked out but
there's enough information which came
from multiple
former and current employees to paint a
damning picture
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has been looking through the
report
david the report was prepared by an
independent firm
quintet consulting which was hired by
the privy council office
or pco in late august to investigate
media reports of a troubled workplace at
rideau hall
thanks to access to information laws we
now have the
heavily redacted report and it documents
a workplace
where yelling screaming aggressive
conduct demeaning comments and
public humiliation were common quintet
said
it was overwhelmed by the number of
rideau hall employees
who wanted to provide information of the
150 or so employees
92 volunteered to be interviewed
between october 19th and november 23rd
quintet in fact had so much material
employees wanted to give it that it had
to limit the interview times
most of those interviewed had worked for
more than one governor general like
david johnston or
mikhail john of the 92 interviewed only
10 had positive or neutral assessments
of the workplace under julie payette and
most were speaking out for the first
time
current employees and past employees had
a significant fear
around reprisal so they were concerned
that if they came forward and complained
about
the public humiliation the toxic work
environment they might lose their jobs
and while payette had said she welcomed
the independent review
a close reading of censored sections of
the quintet report
suggests that payet or her hand-picked
top aide
did not cooperate with quintet's
investigation
there wasn't really an acknowledgement
from the management side or the
mothership level
that um you know toxicity was an issue
in the workplace and as an employment
lawyer i can tell you
that's extremely troubling and the next
human resources headache for the trudeau
government
might be right around the corner an
investigation into workplace harassment
at the canadian museum of history in
gatineau quebec has just been finished
and that report was turned over to the
government
this morning donna okay david aiken in
ottawa thanks
the reality of immunity inequality
coming up the agonizing wait for
vaccines in some of the world's poorest
nations
while canada and other first world
nations complain of a scarce vaccine
supply many other countries around the
world have yet to receive
any doses the world's poorest countries
have been left waiting for help
from the wealthiest countries crystal
gomencing explains
with a coronavirus variant of concern
ripping through the south african
population
protection from the virus is critical
yet there are only a handful of
vaccination campaigns
underway on the african continent
mauritius
has started vaccinations since two days
ago
using the asteroids astrazeneca vaccine
and the data that we have received this
morning she's showing that um
close to 450 people have already been
immunized um morocco received
1.5 million doses last week
and is going to start vaccination
tomorrow seychelles is the most
advanced roughly 25 000 people have been
vaccinated
using two different vaccines including
some shots from astrozenica
donated by india many african countries
and low-income nations elsewhere in the
world
are waiting for discounted or donated
vaccines from the world health
organization
and its kovacs partnership canada has
pledged to hand over its
excess doses and has committed 440
million dollars in support
i think the first doses available to the
kovacs facilities will start in february
this year
and then in march in april there's going
to be a rapid scale up
you know of doses dr robin nandy says
the hope is for
30 percent of health care workers and
high risk people
across africa to be vaccinated by
the end of 2021 a stark contrast to
vaccine goals in europe
and north america randall hansen sees a
potential
silver lining in the inequality and the
quicker that they're up and running
the quicker it will be that we actually
have the wealth to vaccinate
the global south as countries wait for a
vaccine
ground work is being done so health care
workers will be ready to get
shots in arms as fast as possible
crystal gavinson global news london
this is lebanon's lockdown still ahead
the rage of a nation in crisis
that is russian opposition leader alexei
navalny denouncing a court ruling that
rejected an appeal of his arrest
navalny told the court you won't succeed
in scaring tens of millions of people
who have been robbed by the government
he was taken into custody january 17th
when he returned from germany where he
spent five months recovering
from nerve agent poisoning he blames on
the kremlin
navalny's supporters are organizing
another round of mass protests across
russia
on sunday
police have been rounding up his
associates this doctor played the piano
while her apartment was raided today
navalny's wife and brother have also
been detained
people took to the streets in poland
tonight
angry about a court ruling which
effectively bans abortion
in october poland's highest court rule
terminating a pregnancy because of a
fetal defect is
unconstitutional abortion will now only
be permitted in cases of rape or incest
or when the mother's health or life is
in danger the french european affairs
minister tweeted today it is a reminder
rights can
recede if they are not defended
and in lebanon security forces fired
tear gas at protesters angry about
strict
lockdown measures and poor living
conditions this is the fourth straight
day of violence
at least one person was killed hundreds
of others injured
the unrest marks a major escalation in
frustration over the pandemic that is
worsening at an unprecedented
economic and financial time in lebanon a
surge in cases has triggered a
month-long
nationwide lockdown and around-the-clock
curfew pakistan's supreme court has
ruled four men convicted of kidnapping
and murdering american journalist
danielle pearl should be
freed the white house calls it an
affront to terrorism victims
everywhere ahmed omar saeed sheikh a
british national was considered the
ringleader in the 2002 kidnapping and
killing of pearl
pearl was the wall street journal south
asia bureau chief
assailants later filmed pearl's
beheading and sent the video to u.s
officials
in december a court ordered all four men
be set free
both the pearl family and pakistani
authorities appealed that decision and
today the supreme
court ruled against them the white house
is demanding pakistan review its legal
options
including allowing the united states to
prosecute sheikh
a team from the world health
organization has emerged from quarantine
now in wuhan china to begin work on
tracing the origins of covet 19.
they left their hotel to prepare for
field work and their first face-to-face
meeting with chinese scientists
the researchers plan to visit hospitals
labs and markets
and hope to speak with patients and
first responders
the fact-finding mission is politically
charged though china has avoided any
blame for alleged missteps in its early
response to the outbreak
the team is expected to stay in china
for two more weeks
the woes of wall street next the stock
market set up and the chat room where it
happened
you may have heard a lot of talk about
gamestop it's a david and goliath battle
between wall street's financial elite
and some small investors people have
banded together online to drive up the
stock price of gamestop a money losing
chain
of video game stores that company's
stock was trading for less than twenty
dollars a share
and then recently it began to soar as
investors snapped it up
on wednesday it closed at almost three
hundred and fifty dollars a share
jackson proskow explains how and why
this all happened
this was the week wall street got a run
for its money
social media average joes versus big
money players and guess what the army of
average joes are winning
so far those average joes have been on a
buying spree
snapping up shares of troubled companies
blackberry
amc theaters american airlines and the
big one
gamestop the struggling video game
retailer
i'm a blue collar investor right so i'm
i scrap all the time but now
when you get something like this it's
one of those all-in type things for days
the little guys have been cashing in
all while hedge funds lose billions it's
just a way of attacking wealthy people
and you know i think it's inappropriate
we all gotta work together and pull
together
you see unlike average investors big
hedge funds can actually profit from a
struggling business
it's called shorting if a stock price
drops they make
money but if the price rises they stand
to lose
that's where reddit's wall street bets
message board enters the story
when users saw hedge funds had bet
against gamestop and others
they banded together to buy shares
raising the price and reaping the
rewards
there is something to be said about the
fact that pretty much anybody can do it
too and watching them do it collectively
is certainly
certainly a show ironically this modern
day robin hood tale
also involves a stock trading app called
robinhood
which small investors used to snap up
all that shorted stock
but the hero turned villain as robin
hood and other brokerage sites
suddenly banned users from trading the
most volatile shares
shutting out anyone who wanted to cash
in amateur investors are really
necessary for
the health of the market so you want
them in the market
but you don't want them triggering
irrational results risky as their
investments may have been
those amateur investors turned the
financial world upside down
by finding a way to beat wall street at
its own game
jackson prosko global news washington
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's york canada is ottawa's reno
canal
it has opened for the first skate only
locals allowed though keeping in line
with ontario's pandemic restrictions
skaters have to wear face masks and for
now only a third of the canal is open
other sections are
will open once ice conditions are deemed
safe in a normal year about 1700
visitors take a trip on the beautiful
canal every day
thanks for watching robin gill will be
here tomorrow i'll see you on saturday
for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye